oh hey welcome to a new project camp
update this week was quite busy we were
brass cutting preparing the ground for
new people to come
and we already have two new helpers from
the netherlands powder and devi they
will build some jogger decks in the
rocky area of the
land we also fire up the oven we make
pizza we bake the bread for the week
so be ready
grab your popcorn and enjoy the video
so we're gonna clean up our area
just make some space so we have a
spot for the tents to be placed because
some more people are gonna come there is
a flat area just next to the toilet
where the grass is still quite high and
there are some brumbles that need to be
cut
and
yesterday we already cut some mimosa
trunks so they're gonna serve for a
little
step stairs towards the land
[Music]
yeah this is where the the tents are
going to be placed it's quite flat if
you see
compared to the rest of the land
uh but not really accessible so we're
gonna take out some the trunks make some
steps over here
make maybe a place of washing line so
it's a real home
for the people that are gonna come in
total we have three big tents but for
now we start with two
[Music]
this
[Music]
this one there
[Music]
you see it there there's a over here
here
i already started this one the big one
yeah you see the cuts
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
more
hey
[Music]
gonna go use it for the
stairs
there
hey
[Music]
[Music]
uh
but they also break fast if you grab
them
yeah it's kind of okay
some are a bit sharp
on the legs then they scratch over me
getting rid of myself
they are always really high
yeah we need i'm going to cut the grass
with the bush cutter because it's
pressure bush cutter
yes
okay so i'm going to cut the grass today
and
then we have a better idea of how the
serve surfaces and if we need to flatten
parts out
so that's what i'm gonna do
hello otis
what's that what's that
what's this
hello sir would you like to talk to us
well he seems a bit shy
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
okay so
we are at the point that we are going to
make little steps
so the other day we already cut some
parts of mimosa wood
we sharpen the
yeah or the point and now we will smash
them into the ground
one each
or one here and one on the other side so
we can place a wood in the back
and that will shape our
stairs
so last year jan already made some of
these steps and they really helped to
create a little path
in the land
[Music]
okay
this one
also a good way to
um
like use the mimosas right
yeah exactly
they
also if you dry the wood it's nice
we also need to make a place to store it
okay so we made some steps
[Laughter]
hello
how are you
how are you
[Music]
how are you
go to julie
apparently not dog proof
so today we flatten up the space took
some leftover brumbles and made some
steps so now people can easily access
the area
tomorrow some cutting of me monsters
placing the washing line and
building up the tent
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so the menu for today is um we have some
veggies here we're gonna make them in
the wok
we're gonna put some rice with it and
we're
gonna put some salt you need to make it
a bit more tasty
what kind of sauce
i know yeah there's a secret sauce
that i don't know yet
from spain
[Music]
[Music]
vegan not spiders
[Music]
super nice
yeah
i like to like
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
it's the green bag down there actually
and the blue one are there back
of that one the blue one is the likes of
the green one
this guy is the lights
oh yeah okay then this goes back
let's
[Music]
[Music]
and then we make a little bit more grass
work
and then we put up the pan for the
guests
[Music]
you want to carry together
now i'm going down this one
yes no problem for me no problemo
so we're back on the grass patch we're
gonna
place today the tent on the surface that
we yesterday cleaned and flattened
yeah so the tent is gonna be set up for
the people that are gonna come to help
is this quite flattish yeah yeah
because it will be like really feels
like
to me
oh come back
look at you
it's summer again
and you're out again
um it was from the military now like the
dutch military tent
i think from an old couple that were
very sad to give the tent away because
they love it so much but
they wouldn't use it again
but
adrien and i were trying to figure out
there is a lot of crosses over
[Music]
not like this not like that more likely
more like this doesn't it look like the
same kind
there is a
slight angle in there
[Music]
okay this will go inside
[Laughter]
oh yeah it's in the middle
in
yeah that's why there is this bottom
thing
i remember remember
and you feel it also from the bottom
what you mean ah this is the bottom very
sweaty
okay
this is here
[Music]
more
water
you know like i have
300 grams of water and 400 of flour
yeah i have imagine 400 of water or
flour for 200 of water
ah i thought like one to five no no
flour to water
the other way around
[Music]
um
[Music]
we are firing up the oven we built the
last year
so we fire it once a week and we bake
our bread and our pizza
[Music]
how long does it take to have the right
temperature
[Music]
maybe too big guys
[Music]
so
we also make our own bread
you can even check it on the research
model of the website
we have our sourdough and baked bread
for
the whole community once a week
[Music]
yeah this is the dough for the pizza
today we have some visitors so we went a
bit
more crazy with the amount of dough
huh
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
i don't know can you make pizza and play
your harmonica today
how can you do both at the same time i'm
not sure
uh we should do it with the players
players
uh-huh but now it's completely out again
yeah i don't know what happened
[Applause]
[Music]
funny all the um
[Music]
[Music]
squares
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's it for the week i hope you
enjoyed the video thanks for watching
if you want to support us be sure to
subscribe to our channel or visit
support.breadcamp.com
take care and goodbye
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]